cats fingers
Stephen
nightmares
solid week
this is cat fingers oh I could have done
without this episode buggy if it's fine
there's nothing wrong it but uh well we
learned a very important point
cats are evil well we already knew that
but they could shape-shift
now cats the gemstone that we don't know
yeah um um well well we did find out you
looked it up and she is British hearing
our guard garden was that garnet yeah I
I don't listen to music ever so like I
know it's Estelle but I wouldn't
recognize it from yeah it was driving me
nuts so I find me to look it up because
I'm like who is that and she does good
thank you um but yeah so this is an
episode where they find out they can
shape-shift as people wants to try it
like he gives a little cat finger it
tries again he gets you know four more
and they puts on the other hand and then
they can Johnson sooo they can't stop
they trick the sort of this like hand
you stop or cat stuff uh haha so it
turns this Acura monster or a Katra or
katsuo
monster at the end I just skip say don't
look at me Dad goomy goomy
and then uh the dance praise him with
water it's okay so that's alley much but
uh I don't know it goes pretty unnerving
for me just with all the cats are taking
over there like rolling odds eye and
stuffing we gotta go here it should have
been net coke Kira cuz net go is
Japanese hey Joel was in this episode
yeah Joel from mystery science theater I
believe I mean it said Johansson it kind
of sounded again yes anna liam so has
this weird mayor character uh I'm
curious to see papal of guy now that I'm
off the satellite of love I thought I
would run for mayor in this obscure
beach town again cuz he's being
reelected um but uh yeah just uh cats
growing on yeah I never thought that
would be a legit like fear but now I can
this because that was a close very
terrifying yeah hey bet you'll never
look at cats same way again
okay well the blood actually that'd be
no you know said there's something
actually even creepier when there's not
blonde org or anything just something
about it I just said they're going
through the little car wash and they're
just like shape-shifting and warping in
the Attic something looks just amethyst
I hope you responsible for this that's
fair
um I guess that was the most important
thing like I do like how every episode
we're learning a little more about the
gemstone mythos yeah if you will and
this when we learned that they can
shape-shift I this this is news to me I
did not know that you know it uh I put I
just it doesn't feel like they're just
pulling it out of their asses either it
sort of sounds like it can always chase
it don't you know that asshole no nobody
yeah you know I had this plan like it's
gonna build up to something which I kind
of like like you know first episode has
this I that's about to you know come Val
though that does sort of make you ask
why they could shape-shift into a few
other things to stop that I or the
creature or something like that but
because it'll turn into a giant cat
monster were you not watching yeah there
is some sort of like we're
responsibility to it or something I mean
uh that's my love your love it's like
wow this is every crazy cat ladies wet
dream a little boy who turns into a fuck
ton of cats I just think a wife at that
line oh is that my way oh she said that
gesture that we should you want get out
there lie yeah she's she wants so she
walks in and we're watching the show and
it's the intro and she just shoots this
is look and she's like what's this it
were just like Steven universe that she
sits there for a second she's like it
looks like Rainbow Brite crust with Jam
pretty much we could just look over like
next hair X bear it somehow the baked
character is a boy not a girl uh I start
three women as well so maybe then
because I don't know but yeah it does
have that fuel cross-gender appeal it
like I don't I know nothing about the
fan I mean I at kansai I know the adult
fanbase and they they're pretty mixed
but oh yeah I know a challenge I've seen
it boys
girls and men and women dressing up as
characters in the show but I have no
idea what the fan base is what it's
scheduled you know well I think about
this and adventure time even gravity
falls and stuff I think it's one of
those things where it's Ross
yeah you know it's like there's
definitely shows are more geared towards
boys more geared towards girls and if
you're a boy boy boy girl shows are
growing give like boy shows will start
don't lie mention Mike is a boobie but
but there is something about yeah sort
of this mass appeal to everyone show
like there's it seems like there's more
of them and I like that I like shows I
can sort of appeal to both you know boys
it's what I think is it if I'm gonna get
in trouble and it feels like a girl show
to me and there's nothing wrong with
that I just but when I look at like the
way the show is written and everything
you know it fit
it feels that whoever wrote it either
there's a female hand involved or
they're they have a sense of their own
feminine touch it just has that vibe to
it to me and that there's a lot behind
I'm actually enjoying the show a problem
with that but it it gives off that fight
I haven't paid attention to the credits
so I said I should scream ah yeah yeah I
should see who the Creator is and like
but it it just gives off that vibe and I
see I don't mind it's kind of refreshing
like we you know it's done it's done
smart and I think that I think that's
kind of fun thing about now that you do
seem like Adventure Time and other shows
is that they are serve tackling sort of
more feminine issues like you don't come
to grips with your emotions and so forth
let's doing it smart it's doing it
entertaining Lee it's doing it funny and
there's nothing wrong with any of that
stuff
I kind of wish we had more of Matt
growing up in the 80s because girl shows
back then we're just shit you know I
mean that's one of the reason I mean
anyone growing up will tell you like ya
know they they just sucked and not to
say the boy shows head were a lot better
they were bad fucking family tried
harder they were the my little pony of
the 80s
versus what we have now are two vastly
different bees yes um and it's the same
thing with I feel like these
at least a number of these shows aim for
girls out is that this may be part of
why they're appealing to guys as well is
they feel broader where it's like when
we were growing up it really felt like
there were a few odd ones out sheera
fell somewhere in between because it's
connected to the he-man universe but
generally speaking you felt like no
that's for girls I'm are you boy I want
to watch this and it and God help you
watching somebody found out at your
school and you know then you had the boy
shows like gee I join it yeah I feel
like there's this this blending like I
don't care I'm fine with it it's just
it's so different from when we were
growing up you know the environment from
when we were growing up versus what it
is now and I know I like I know a lot of
bronies have a chip on their shoulder
and they still get picked on and this
and that but I imagine in the 80s what
it would have been like oh yeah I can I
can't like and I'm not saying I'm not
saying it's right that anybody today
would get picked out of it I can
guarantee you it would have been a lot
worse
there was definitely you know at times
of is since we were kids times have
changed and I in my opinion for the best
definitely for the bottom so it I think
it's right watch cuz yeah you wouldn't
have seen this sort of cross gender
appeal to a lot of these shows that you
do not like one who's made out here one
or two you know I guess I guess you
could argue Care Bears was kind of cross
gender but you know I I think that we
have more of a feminine those were young
enough I mean those those were for a
little bit a little yeah and I'm in
Chinese Tunes it was like Animaniacs it
was that we cross gender because it just
was a that fell into that that to me was
like the Disney cartoons like rescue
rangers and yeah it would be a generic
cartoon but there were definitely some
that you get Jem would be one of yeah
Rainbow Brite warmers would be boys GI
Joe would be yes you know I would take
back while saying before about like boy
shows being written that much bear you
know they weren't oh no no no we just
like Kabira little boy because we were
little idiots I just wanted violence of
people running around
no they were all of them were just
trying to sell toys and that's not
working oh hey you we all have to sell
though something no I mean you do your
research these were literally made only
to sell toys racing one good story and
selling toy toys is you know probably
more important to you know having a
second season like getting a show off
the ground uh you know you want both you
use ten to one bones we're back then it
was only toys like nothing else and with
uh I think when you have stuff like you
know the tattoos Animaniacs and like
Ninja Turtles not that they were you
know I mean it was great but not the
Ninja Turtles or tattoos were necessary
like high art or huge groundbreakers but
they were starting to get a little
smarter like hey let's throw in some
actual good jokes every once in a while
it's an actual good humor well times was
a way to capitalize on Titus was a
Warner Brothers heritage but I when I
look at Tiny Toons up like this was not
created for the sole purpose of selling
toys transformers ya know it's not even
is it just that's what it was where's
Tiny Toons in it I think it's reflected
in the writing on the show - yeah I mean
there's definitely like go genders
definitely up though so it's like okay
this is this is for the little kids now
but there's definitely episodes and
lines where it's like okay work we're
gonna throw on some good humor because
we want the people watching this to get
good humor and good characters uh but
it's it's it's fascinating to watch
because this is like you know I always
wondered what it was like to like grow
up like during the race riots in my be
early 60s and then like you're living
nowadays where things have changed you
know for the better unless you're some
crazy fuck a lot of good bad weirder but
yeah fuck those guys um you know and
it's the same thing here and like we
still have a long way to go but I don't
you know same way where things have
changed for the better I'm like huh I'm
like yeah you and they're like you could
not be caught if you went into your
school and like now like you know
Romy's have their own groups and things
and like you you couldn't do it any of
these your job wouldn't and unless I'm
with you and I start arguing no I would
argue that even though even though I
agree I mean it's like you know whatever
equality when a race gender everything
is never going to be perfect and yes
there's always go I really think in the
past ten to eight years there have been
some huge leaps into this stuff because
I think we did grow up in the 80s where
it was just like even though there were
some gender neutral shows uh it was like
if there's a girl show it was only a
girl show there's a boy show it was only
a boy show and there was like just this
if so we pander to and here you have a
show that had said don't worry that's
totally heavy and ER - yeah I don't I
could watch the show and say it feels to
me like it has a very feminine it feels
very right and it does not it feel that
it is pandering though yeah like this is
some cheap shield to be like you know
here it's got pink on it you're a girl
you're gonna like it like yeah yeah it
feels like there is thought and effort
put into this you can try it is not like
hey I'm looking for a gun I'm looking to
shoot say I have a sword I ever you know
he's a very fragile boy you know he
cries is much like it I never wanted I
know rolling away kid yeah it is I said
it it's just refreshing like it is uh
and I I liked it and the biggest thing
about doing this I always say with
anything whatever someone's like we
can't do this with race you can't do
this with gender you came to this with
sexuality whatever your limiting your
options your limiting possibilities
there are so many options so many
possibilities and I think it's reflected
in a show like this and other shows are
doing something similar so whenever you
say you know when you can't do something
with whatever a transgender transsexual
gay black age whatever you're limiting
what you can do and there's just so much
fun that can be had so many
possibilities and it's been we got a
show tonight yeah it's just one of those
things where it's like it just gets
boring and you just keep yourself in a
box unless you expand a let you look
girls down twice as many toys as boys
why are you marketing any actually good
toys or girls all right girls down by as
much no no I love the voices
self-fulfilling prophecy with these
assholes yeah I got a plan - we don't
want to be itself it's like well
Supergirl and Catwoman didn't make money
well you gotta make good fucking movies
before people are gonna do some date in
May
honey I remember the Turner's don't beg
that doesn't make a cat so fucking idiot
no but that's why
see that's why I get much more happy and
excited why I see a children show doing
this kind of thing because this is the
next Jeanette's preparing the next say
Oh what are you talking about these
animal with crusty white assholes
running these studios are gonna die and
then eventually the next generations
gonna take over no I gotta help us
please no I'm with you I think they are
it really is past couple years we've
seen so much more possibilities open up
I mean really even with movies even
though we can say we like to see more
but I mean that they're really straight
I've lost of being done with movies
would have been done you know in the 80s
either now we're seeing nowadays uh and
it's wonderful and like you said there's
still ways to go but it's it's happening
and the change is happening people are
seeing the possibilities and they're
seeing the fun and they're say hey let's
try this cuz there's really nothing to
lose there's only stuff to gain it's
happening rich can't you see something's
happening
oh so uh yeah that's our fun little rant
I didn't think I would we would get this
kind of rant from - uh it was perfect
cuz there's nothing much else to talk
about this I wanted to spell the myth we
get all sorts of business being like oh
my god they mention my little pony
welcome to the herd or oh my god the
minute talk about my little pony I can't
believe you guys it's such assholes that
you hate all bronies with it I will
mention this straight up I when I heard
the show was coming back it was a huge
hit with a male audience older male
audience yeah I I didn't get it mostly
because I remembered what I grew up with
in the 80s I'm like what would appeal
and I'm not saying that it can't appeal
to male demographic I'm just saying I
think it was really a good trip for
girls right this limbs a cheap chill
show so I watched a few episodes I'm
like okay I get it like I could see why
anybody would like this and it's
legitimately funny in spots it's not my
thing
I honestly I would much rather watch
Steven universe then I would watch you
know the new incarnation my little pony
but then it's not anything against
people want to watch it and I don't hate
it it's just everybody has their thing
they
rabbit right towards and this is more my
thing I in I like the artwork on this
show better
I like the music just everything about
the show appeals to my personal taste so
go nuts if you want to be a brony go
nuts if you like Steven Yeun effect go
nuts like it both of them there's one
gram but yeah I did want to kind of
address that because like I it's so
interesting the way God things have
changed so much since we were kids and
like I'm glad for it I'm very happy I
like I said it just it just opens up so
much more and you know like I said I
mean we kind of went through that dead
zone in the 80s with cartoons just being
so formulaic and boring for the most
part you know until we got stuff like
the Disney Afternoon and stuff and then
we started to go through that in with
movies in the late 90s and early 2000s
where just everything was so formulaic
and boring and in this fucking box and
it now with both were expanding much
more cuz we're seeing hey there's really
nothing wrong with taking a girl and
make it more masculine or taking a boy
maybe more feminine you can do it and
you can find much more possibilities you
have much more fun and you can see stuff
that's new and I love them I love that
we're living in time where this change
is happening in it feels likes appening
quickly as well just tell a good story
yeah that's you know it's so easy in yet
on the other hand it's so complicated do
it but if you tell a good story first
can worry about all that other shit
later and I think that's why the recent
incarnations of these shows even like
stepping outside of something like My
Little Pony we even go to teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles I think that's why the
reason the incarnations have been
generally working I think there's this
thought like you know we're past the
point you know we can keep doing this to
sell toys but at some point we got to
still tell a story and I think we're
seeing more and more of that what I'm
seeing that that's what's gonna bring
people back uh and if anything doing the
more go cross-gender thing uh where you
hit both males and females it just gets
a wider audience you know it just gets
more people involved cuz you're getting
both genders girls barrel boys many toys
how many times do I need to shout it so
yeah I'm thrilled that this changes
and at the speed it's happening and you
know of course there's gonna be whatever
someone some eight-year-old stuck in the
forties for some reason be like Carol's
can't do blah blah blah blah when when
you see Toys R Us go out of business
because of your business decisions um so
I hope you're happy you put all of
America's tweakers I'm a jobs because of
girl damn girls
so um yeah that's about all we got like
I said do you think we could get this
from cat fingers well we had to go
somewhere for the X fingers so um Oh
hopefully we'll have a more episodes end
third one the next time around but why'd
you find out by clicking on the next one
go